brad pitt on depression addiction and
his future in hollywood jesse smollette
opens up about his time behind bars lord
knows i wanted to get out
and then psych ward you're just left
there with you your thoughts
and these walls
watch kim kardashian's kids crash her
tonight show appearance i'm dying i'm
hearing kids guys can you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me
your kids are right there um
and only e.t is with 1883 stars tim
mcgraw and faith hill on their acting
futures i'd like to see her be a badass
in something kick somebody's butt i play
a cia agent or something like that et's
the download starts right now
brad pitt is getting vulnerable in a new
interview with gq he's on the cover of
the august issue out july 17th and
admits that after his split with ex-wife
angelina jolie he's six years sober and
spent a year and a half in alcoholics
anonymous he says i think i spent years
with a low-grade depression and it's not
until coming to terms with that trying
to embrace all sides of self the beauty
and the ugly that i've been able to
catch those moments of joy another habit
he's been able to curb is smoking he
quit cold turkey during the pandemic
adding that he doesn't have it in him to
just cut back now back in 2020 when he
was honored by the national board of
review for his reporting role in once
upon a time in hollywood he credited his
friendship with bradley cooper for
helping him get healthy i got sober
because of this guy
and every day has been happier ever
since i love you and i thank you
well it's it's nice to be able to leave
this thing carrying something other than
george clooney
my goals in life now are pretty simple
just to
be happy
stay healthy
and not get into a financial situation
where i have to do ocean's 14.
despite starring in bullet train
opposite sandra bullock out august 5th
brad says he considers himself on his
last leg
yeah i know and he's carefully plotting
his future in hollywood which will
likely focus on more behind the camera
his production company's responsible for
critically acclaimed films like minari
moonlight and 12 years a slave there's
the proof right there even if he's not
in front of the camera he's still making
hits don't crush it listen if he doesn't
if he does stop acting by the way he'll
always be a heartthrob here's what he
told us 28 years ago i mean who's gonna
complain
i mean i don't want that to be the main
emphasis is what i understand yeah it's
gravy and it's lovely are you kidding me
yeah i mean listen you go through all of
high school try to get that and now on
to jesse smallett he's still proclaiming
his innocence after he was found guilty
of lying to police about being attacked
in hate crime last year in a new serious
xm interview jesse talks about his time
in jail and refusing to eat while he was
locked up i was there for six and a half
days that's what we do in my family like
we fast
for
for clarity i have never in my life been
as clear of mind as i was for those six
and a half days lord knows i wanted to
get out
a little psych ward on you know and they
have you in a jacket no no no they
didn't have me in a jacket but they had
me i was sleeping on her on like a like
a restraint bed you're just left there
with you your thoughts
and these walls
he credits his family and friends for
helping him get through it one in
particular his empire co-star taraji p
henson it is unexplainable
how much i love that woman and
she is literally one of my best
friends in the whole world and i love
her and i'm always just
i just
i just i love her
jesse who turned 40 yesterday says his
biggest regret is that infamous gma
interview with robin roberts where he
denied the hate crime was a hoax
i'm pissed off
what
is it that has you so
angry listen if i tell the truth
then
that's it because it's the truth
i was mortified
i mean i was mortified i mean i cringed
at just the
every single word that i said in that
interview was the truth
but there was a certain level of
performative
nature that came from it because i
didn't want to be there
and i was so angry and so offended that
i had to go on national television and
explain something that happened to me
okay guys we are in pulling in the
parking lot
in new york in new york oh kim
kardashian found out boys will be boys
on a trip to the tonight show in new
york that news tops tonight's talk show
circus yeah her son saint and some
crashed her ig live last night and root
to see jimmy fallon say hi hi
this is called instagram live hi weirdos
hey stop it hi
if you're watching this i hate you
hey look what you're teaching them oh
kids
what's up they're a bunch of weirdos but
also kim is in some drama right there
okay the chaos did not stop in the car
midway through her tv interview kim had
stepped back into mommy mode
uh i'm getting i'm hearing kids guys can
you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me please your
kids are right there um
well that is
my boys are here and i hear them making
so much noise guys this is your first
time at work with me don't mess this up
they don't care what did you expect kids
don't get there i think you won't see my
kids here at work oh we never get
through a single story
later in the interview kim revealed this
pop culture blind spot i have to be
honest i had never seen snl before i'd
gone to one taping of eddie murphy but i
had never and i and i'd gone backstage
you've never see you've never seen sarah
live no like serious here i'm dead
serious
i i gotta be honest i
had no idea you were on
i was at dinner and will ferrell
mentioned he'd seen it and i literally
had to text pete and be like wait it was
will ferrell on snl
and i was so embarrassed like i
literally i i've been schooled i know
everyone that's been on now i know oh my
god
in more tv news sherry sheppard's new
daytime talk show just announced a
september 12 premiere date the former
co-host of the view will film in front
of a live studio audience featuring a
daily dose of pop culture comedy and
human interest interviews the news comes
just days after the comedian hosted the
series finale of the wendy williams show
her new show will fill that time slot
most of all we have to thank you wendy
williams
because yes
there is nobody
nobody like wendy williams
from her days on the radio to ruling
daytime talk for 13 seasons
wendy earned her title as the queen of
all media
meanwhile the third season of umbrella
academy is out on netflix and star
elliott page who came out as trans in
december 2020 tells seth myers his
character in the show also transitions
this season when we first talked about
it he
seemed really excited about
incorporating it into the show
were the people closest to you in your
real life
as supportive as the people on the show
yeah absolutely
i feel really grateful for that i think
most people weren't surprised what i
want to focus on right now and is been
so extraordinary is the degree of joy
that i feel
the degree of presence that i feel
i feel a way that i really
never thought thought possible for uh
for a long long time
i actually talked with the rest of the
cast about what it was like to be part
of elliott and his character victor's
journey
it was really emotional um you know
ellie and i are really really close in
real life and be able to share that with
him on screen as victor and allison was
was really really emotional i remember
just
making sure i was off book because it
was such a powerful scene and i was like
i just need to make sure i give it as
much effort as i as i can because i felt
like it was part of
something part of history and tv history
i think it was handled the way
brilliantly actually and exactly as it
should be and it was handled quite
quickly really but i think it's the
immediate acceptance of the characters
of victor
that is so well done
on to elvis hitting theaters friday
pretty good right that was pretty sorry
austin
michelle turner he's kind of a job for
the sequel uh the shelter was there as
three generations of presley women were
all honored in a hollywood ceremony fit
for the king ladies and gentlemen
the presley family
when i first came to l.a back in 1962
this is one of the first places we drove
by and he told me that these are all the
hands
uh that are in acting in the who's who
you know this is kind of an honor of him
as well elvis ex-wife priscilla was
joined by daughter lisa marie and three
granddaughters including riley keough
and i just had to get their honest
review of austin butler's portrayal of
elvis before the movie hits theaters
friday never met anyone like you
i hope not i loved seeing the birth of
your relationship in this movie what
made you fall in love with him oh what
was there not to fall in love with
[Laughter]
oh my god i mean he was he was an
amazing human being i'm ready ready to
fly watching him play your fight it did
something to me it really did and so
what did it do to you oh a lot a lot i
wasn't ready for what it did that's kind
of left me alone in the theater the
first time i saw it after the film i
just fell into him in tears
the moment that i saw austin
on stage i started crying just feeling
in that moment like they really got him
you're looking for trouble
you came to the right place
now that you've seen it now that you've
heard yourself does it give you more
confidence i don't know what the future
holds but
i just i just rest in the fact that that
was the time of my life
[Music]
someone else having the time of their
life kate bush well that's thanks to
stranger things her song running up that
hill just hit number one on the uk
charts and it turns out kate's music
also
almost made it into another big project
christian bale who plays gore the god
butcher and thor love and thunder tells
total film magazine director taika
wattidi planned out a dance sequence for
the character featuring bush's music but
it was scrapped because he didn't think
he would be allowed to use it in the
final film i mean what a missed
opportunity i mean come on i love the
idea that there's going to be a dance
yeah thor come on especially since kate
tells bbc radio 4 the original title of
her song running up that hill was a deal
with god and also admits her newfound
attention is still a shock but it's just
extraordinary i mean
you know it's such a great series i
thought that the track would get some
attention
but um i just never imagined that it
would be anything like this it's um
it's so exciting the whole world's gone
mad what's really wonderful i think is
that this is a whole new audience who
you know in a lot of cases they've never
heard of me and i love that
the social bodies
really young people hearing the song for
the first time and discovering it
is well i think it's very special camila
cabello is sparking relationship rumors
the new pigs top tonight
[Music]
camila is back on her feet and back on
the dating scene seven months after her
split from shawn mendes the singer was
spotted look in smith last week in
hollywood with austin kevich a source
tells e.t austin asked mutual friends to
set him up with camilla and that the
pair went out and had fun together
austin knows a thing or two about dating
he's the ceo behind locks club billed as
a culturally jewish members only dating
app for people with ridiculously high
standards how about that yeah someone
else who probably has high standards
michael b jordan the actor deleted all
traces of ex lori harvey from his
instagram weeks after the pair called it
quits laurie did her own social media
scrub right after the breakup the source
told et at the time that the two were
heartbroken but at different stages in
their lives laurie's dad steve harvey
also weighed in on the split
i'm team lori so i mean i'm a team lori
1 000
you know she's my daughter i love her i
support her you know things happen it's
hard to be
young and and in the limelight and have
a successful relationship
i can almost hear everybody asking what
is mbj looking for next a nice smile and
a laugh and a sense of humor is really
sexy
well there's probably a lot of laughter
in kristen bell in dax shepard's
household kristen spilling her marriage
secrets telling cbs mornings the pair
are polar opposites and the key is
meeting in the middle
you have to have diverse points of view
people who have different roads to get
there because uh you know a recipe is
not delicious with one ingredient right
so that's just not how it works
and they told us last year on the set of
their game show family game night
working together helps too when we have
a shared goal
at work and we play off of each other
really well that just makes us feel more
connected you really come to rely on
each other in a way that reminds you
like oh right i have this amazing human
in my life and uh i get to work with him
kobe bryant's baby girl is growing up
his widow vanessa just wished their
youngest capri or coco a happy third
birthday on the gram and wow she is
looking a lot like her dad look at that
i mean while vanessa celeb friends
including sierra lala anthony and khloe
kardashian all show some love in the
comments kobe of course died in the same
helicopter crash that killed his 13 year
old daughter gianna in 2020 and last
week's for father's day the fam visited
his childhood home in philly and look
the basketball court where kobe used to
play as a kid is now dedicated to the
boat
sticking with the world of sports the
nfl is about to get a little less fun
that's because rob gronkowski is
retiring he broke the news on twitter
tuesday saying i will now be going back
into my retirement home walking away
from football again with my head held
high knowing i gave it everything i had
good or bad every time i stepped out on
the field gronk first announced his
first retirement back in 2019 but had a
change of heart when his buddy tom brady
asked him to join the tampa bay bucks
they went on to win the 2021 super bowl
now back in march he dropped a hint to
e.t that this time might be up i love
the game of football but it's a lot it's
a big grind so i'm just putting it you
know in the back seat right now uh
you know it will always be there if i if
i stay in shape i'm just chilling right
now and i'll let that play out in the
future gronk's model girlfriend camille
kostak is showing her support but tom
brady is making his own nfl comeback
next season and she made this prediction
to e.t you're betting woman does rob go
back or doesn't he i say he does you
think he does
that's mostly because i hope he does to
me the game of football isn't the same
without without him and especially now
without brady so
but camille is all for it now she shared
a pic of him on the gram captioned dream
chasers in the house
wow from goat's body to man's best
friend
et's rachel smith shows us how the pups
at the westminster dog show become top
dogs
hey guys i'm hanging out the westminster
kennel club dog show with my buddy riff
yes he's a cutie patootie isn't he and
i'm getting all the tea on the oscars
for dogs
we have dogs from 49 states and nine
other countries almost 3 200 dogs in the
dog's show alone generally if someone
wins best in show the dog is retired
from showing because there's really
nowhere else to go retire
quit while you're ahead
the grand prize here at the 146th annual
westminster kennel club dog show with
the lindhurst estate is not money but
prestige what happens behind the scenes
lots and lots of pampering how long does
it take you to brush this a good three
hours you want them
wider in the rear than in the front
cooper got back that's for sure if you
picture cooper as a celebrity who would
that celebrity be bradley cooper oh
matthew mcconney totally out there he
goes to his own beat all right
i think brad pitt i think mcguire would
be brad pitt and her name again saida
mean mooty born houseman
that's her name yeah i need to give me
the abbreviated version honey because i
ain't remembering that so i just got a
hair dryer a flat iron honey high
maintenance i mean
best in show airs tonight on fox sports
but today's big winner me give me good
food give me that food oh my gosh
congratulations oh wow right in the
mouth folks
oh and guys you're gonna have to hang
with us tomorrow because we're gonna
have best in show dog right here on e.t
for you right ref griff says rough and
back to y'all oh yep let's go play bye
guys
guess what i wear is a hat
a lentil
one time i nibbled on a piece of cheese
and my cholesterol went up to 900.
you don't understand i'm obsessed with
that little guy that is marcel the shell
the character voiced by jenny slate
racked up millions of views on youtube
in his debut a decade ago now he's the
star of a new movie out friday and
you'll see him on commentator duty at
the westminster dog show this week and
maybe have the hound group in the ring
please
bloodhound that's just that's such a
scary sounding name i mean if i were to
name this dog i would just call him
velvet wrinklehound it was so funny to
us just marcel like just talking about a
husky or whatever is just uh he has so
many questions do you hope your daughter
becomes a marcel fan she does love
marcel's voice i like her thinking of it
as something that like
mom does you know like like i i think
i don't know that you'll ever be able to
separate me and him and
i think that's okay
you may remember jenny had a brief stint
on snl in 2009 since then she's had a
consistent career in both film and tv
she explained to e.t what that
experience taught her hong kong i think
i would tell myself that um there are
secret doors in every experience every
experience um hopefully
will lead to something new where you can
find something else out about yourself
jenny was out by the time andy bryant
joined the cast she of course announced
her departure after 10 years last month
along with kate mckinnon pete davidson
and kyle mooney and today she's telling
variety she would have quit snl years
ago if it weren't for the pandemic she
says when covet hit it was jarring that
we were all like i'm definitely going to
come back next year a.d told us in
february that time brought the cast
closer these like covet years have
played a part in that where it's like oh
god it feels kind of normal and nice to
like hold on to each other and stick in
the routine even if it's changing all
the time 80 returned for season 47
because she missed a lot of the previous
years shooting her hulu show shrill she
says i kept trying to seek one last
normal year and 10 felt like a nice
solid round number 80 will be watching
the new cast and would definitely love
to come back and host but that decision
is up to the show yeah well tim mcgraw
and faith are also ready for more on
camera moments only e.t talks to the
country couple about a possible upcoming
project
[Applause]
and the impressive act that has sofia
vergara hitting that golden buzzer on
agt et's the download we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
how does shooting this season compare to
the four prior it's it's really good to
be out there i mean honestly it's hard
to get tired of those mountains and
rivers and horses and things like that
i really don't want to give away too
much kevin costner keeping tight-lipped
about yellowstone season 5 to et's
cassie dolores she tried she tried she
caught up with the actor on the blue
carpet for paramount pluses uk launch
also there the stars of the yellowstone
spin-off 1883 tim mcgraw and faith hill
only e.t talked to the couple about
whether they'll ever share the screen
again
i would love to do something else
absolutely it was i i really did love it
would you want to do another project
with tim again now absolutely not
i'm kidding okay
what kind of role would you like to see
her i don't know i'd like to see her be
a badass at something you know
kick somebody's butt
play a cia agent or something like that
it'll be the last thing you do 1883 is
getting some emmy buzz thanks in part to
the sparks that fly on screen between
tim and faith but filming almost an
entire series outside in the elements
was an intense experience how was it for
you
leaving your character behind i didn't
have any trouble at all
i was so tired by the end of it i went
through a little bit of a depression i
have to say for about a couple of weeks
i was just
really sad how did you transition out of
your character i'm a mom of three i'm a
wife you know so i'm a mom of four
really just kidding me
i'm gonna get in so much trouble for
this interview
are you happy the beard is gone
yeah yes i am i think she kind of liked
the beard for a little while you know i
i was tired of it
now your daughter audrey
her singing chops
[Music]
she can sing and gracie as well
[Applause]
gracie wants to be on stage and theater
so they're giving us advice i learned
things from them i mean honestly some
things i wish i didn't know
could you guys ever do
a recording together have you talked
about it i i would i don't know if they
would
because you know they think every all
four of the women in my family can out
see me so i don't know if any of them
would really want to do that
[Applause]
an all-female dance group from lebanon
leaves the judges mesmerized on
america's got talent they couldn't look
away from the mayas and neither
seriously et spoke to judge sophia
vergara back in april and she teased an
added reward that brings the competition
to a whole new level we have an extra
golden buzzer that we had last season
though
and that was that is amazing because
sometimes we feel that there's it's not
fair that we don't have more of them
because everyone is getting so good well
sophia put that twist into play with a
life-changing vote for the mayas it's
time for us to vote and i want to be
part of this
yup sophia slammed that golden buzzer
sending the dance group straight to the
live shows and a shot at the one million
dollar prize oh the golden buzzer gets
you every time for a million dollars
i'll try that
not bad right we could do it daddy let's
do it let's do it
here we go that does it for today
everybody make sure to join us right
here tomorrow totally nailed it we tried
right for a new episode of et's the
download i would hit the buzzer i would
[Music]